so Bill Maher said a while ago we're
going to tone down the attacks against
Trump and his supporters because it
could very well lead to a civil war Bill
Maher actually said that on the show I
didn't really say that that's great yes
that's it for him uh later on he said
there can't be a civil war because the
Mason-Dixon Line would go through Nana's
Kitchen or something like that which is
like a really dumb statement it's like
it's like he thinks time stopped the
moment he said those words bro the
future is a thing and things can change
does he think that like in 1861 they're
like there can't possibly be a civil war
yeah a lot of people thought that
exactly so it's like who do you think
you are you have no idea what could
happen we got all these counties in
Oregon just voted to secede from the
state and join Idaho they literally
voted to do that now whether or not
it'll happen probably not but the
sentiment is there now you have through
obviously there's cultural issues but
ultimately it comes out of tribal issues
for tribal reasons people are choosing
to do things like David Hawk I'm gonna
wear a mask so that no one thinks I'm a
Conservative Republican yeah it's
nothing to do with the CDC guidelines
there was a we had Elijah Shaffer on the
show the other day
and and now he's flying back out he has
his tweet it's fantastic he said they
made an announcement over the over the
uh intercom on the on the plane that
even though the CDC changed the
guidelines on masks the the federal
government is still requiring everybody
abide by this which leaves all of these
people on the plane confused because
they were supposed to do what the CDC
said now they're being told they can't
so anyway I digress on that point
about listening to the science right
right so I bring that up because it is
totally tribal and now we are getting
the physical dividing line between the
tribes well have you ever heard real
quick like when your tribe expands and
contracts well just one more Point
there's a story from NPR that shows
if you if you look at all of the states
on a scale of the highest per capita
vaccinations to the lowest there's a
line right through the middle and
there's like a weird Gap all of the
states that are higher in in per capita
vaccinations who did they vote for
in 2020 I have no idea Joe Biden Joe and
on the other side
they're all red except for the four
states that were contested by Trump and
his team and I think Missouri I'm not
sure Missouri was contested but that
that makes sense it's all kind of you
know it's wingstate all the trumps right
all the Trump supporting states are
lower lower on the vaccination per
capita and the states that were like
really close and were being contested
are also slightly lower and then all the
hard blue Pro Biden States totally like
High 70 75 vaccinations so Washington
they're now rolling out vaccine
passports in New York we're going to see
it everywhere but what's happening is
it's not a hardcore thing where they're
like you know California isn't coming
out and saying You must have a vaccine
passport or else they're saying ah yes
come in and if you're not vaccinated you
can go into the bathroom and sit down
and have your beer but you can't be near
other people they're making people not
participate socially which creates not a
mandate but a social pressure toward
these things which means like I
mentioned people who live in New York
won't live that way will go to Florida
or Texas I know how many people do you
guys know move to Texas recently oh
we had some guests here and I'm not
going to say with the Arts I don't know
if they've announced their mode in Texas
but they're like yeah I'm moving to
Texas and I'm like multiple people yeah
several people and Florida Luke who was
on this show for two months Luger
casting rear change look what are you
doing you traitor he went to Florida
yeah I moved to the South about six
years ago oh how was it went down there
for school and never left so I don't
know anyone who's moving to Texas
because I'm already in the South you
know there's nowhere to go DeSantis is
doing a pretty good job it's not perfect
but nobody is and he's doing a probably
one of the best jobs in the country as a
governor in my opinion and so people
want to be there but I don't like living
in like people need to understand the
humidity oh in Florida is so intense
you're swimming you're like you
basically just Trump left
he's like I'm not I'm not doing this is
going back to New York he's what he's
going back to New York he went back to
New York for the summer he said I'm not
I'm not even gonna be here
he's up in yeah did he get vaccinated he
did they said he did I think Ivanka did
it publicly so I took a picture she did
it publicly but then but then Trump you
know they said he was vaccinated and
Melania before they left the White House
but they you know they never really made
a big public staying out of it what
about Baron a lot of people do
um I don't know yeah yeah no idea he's
not in the at-risk category I wonder if
Trump would do that I just think you
know when New York they've announced
this massive I think it's like a 17
million dollar expansion they're funding
The Excelsior system it's more than just
vaccines The Excelsior system is going
to track your medical history period and
your age and a bunch of other things
which means they could actually say like
you can't be over 55 to come in here
scan your Excelsior pass they're like
they're really getting into this well so
let me go back to what I was going to
say earlier is that you know
people are generally tribal right you
know that's that's how Humanity
developed you know where these bands of
tribes and then as As Cities and then
city-states started to become more
developed
um your your tribe expanded right and so
if you look into I think we're all
generally Millennials slash Elder
Millennials no he's uh I'm kind of I'm
right on the bridge of millennial on gen
Z okay what year were you born uh 95. oh
wow
I might be I don't know I've heard
different definitions
yeah but anyway put it this way so if
you look like 80s 90s you're a
millennial right okay you're you're
sorry your tribe was you was generally
pretty much the United States of America
right you know I'm an American first and
then you're everything else right you're
then you have your religion and then
your state and then what sports team you
like etc etc and then you know the enemy
is the Soviets or you know then
eventually it became you know the
terrorists you have to say it like that
you know really starting past 2008 and
you know I don't want to make this an
Obama thing but like I think it's a word
Financial as well that with that
Financial instability that you saw a
breakup of that idea and so because in
in times of scarcity right the tribes
get smaller and you're because we're
looking now we're thinking instead of
these these abundant uh you know this
idea that oh the future's always going
to be great we're looking at the next
Frontier we're sending space shuttles up
all the time right you know that's my
childhood now I take my kids to Cape
Canaveral the space shuttles are in
museums and Elon Musk and Bezos are like
doing something but we're not really
sure if it's real or not you know yeah
it doesn't it doesn't feel the same or
it doesn't have that same sort of
national uh ethos behind it the same way
the space shuttle program did and and
there's this question of like what team
am I on or someone people question are
you the left or the right you know I
don't even remember anyone talking like
that when I was younger it's like yeah
you know I voted for Democrat I voted
for Republican this time because because
I like this team better I like this
political form better but there wasn't
this idea that you know you had to be on
one side all the time 24 7. and and so
the question you know really
psychologically speaking is is that
something that's Downstream of Economics
uh the same way that you know we say
politics industry from culture but it's
culture Downstream from economics yeah I
mean it's obviously all really
intermingled but there's something
interesting there about resources
Contracting and then people really
wanting to almost oust people from their
side it's almost like this biological
response there's less for all of us so
we need to find a reason to expel people
so that there's more for me it is
fascinating and I think ironically
enough that actually exacerbates the
problem too because the less people are
working together the less able they are
to build up the economic resources that
would allow for them to not have to oust
people you know it's historically part
of what would get people asked to do is
getting sick illness communicable
disease Jesus you know you get you throw
them out of the castle five-year-old has
symptoms throw them out yeah wait wait
even if it's your sister's son or
whatever we need only look at the
chicken society and to learn how
important lesson when a chicken gets
sick or is hobbled or weak they go nuts
they attack it they'll kill it no it's
it's really interesting though uh
because something I just said a moment
ago I I um I want to walk back a little
bit or at least expand upon because I
mentioned that when you start ousting
people or purging them from your group
people aren't working together so you're
less likely to develop the economic
prosperity
that would be necessary for people to
live in harmony but I wonder if that's a
correction mechanism because it's very
much possible and I would say probably a
concrete fact that once people are
really economically prosperous they
become much less selective about the
kind of behavior that they're willing to
tolerate we see this in very developed
countries the moral fabric tends to
begin to dissipate and so maybe hard
Economic Times are a correction
mechanism for that and people sort of
returning to a structure where they are
more selective about the kind of
behavior they'll tolerate because it
can't continue forever without anyone
doing whatever they want or else the
entire system gets destroyed for
thurning
it was bad morals that got us into this
economic we're turning place it seems
like something really weird happened in
the past five years with a dramatic
cultural shift and it's funny left we
bring it up from time to time but left
and right are meaningless at this point
you know sort of I mean sure we use them
as tribal signifiers for the most part I
think I've said this before I do think
that
the left in many ways are descendants
of the initial left when I just look at
this main common threat from the left at
the time of the French Revolution when
the term was first coined has always
existed to oppose the Catholic church
and its values and battle against
tradition
and that's still true today of the left
but there's there's this really strange
shift that happened uh so just before
the show uh I played the song Hit That
by The Offspring and I'm like if you
listen to those lyrics sounds like a
very conservative song it's talking
about the consequences of of hookup
culture and I'm like if you wrote an
article right now no no joke take The
Offspring punk band a pop punk
mainstream whatever but this is 2003
take that song Take the lyrics and turn
it into an article so when they say like
you know the consequences are life away
you can say like your work work imagine
putting into like a relationship article
yeah well you'd be called far right yeah
be called far right yeah criticizing
Tinder and hook up culture and
misogynist the yep
uh you know backwards toxic clearly you
know anti-female uh self-hatred if it
was written by a female law you know
she's internalized patriarchy pure toxic
Purity culture one of my favorite punk
rock songs is why don't you get a job I
know I know it's pop punk it's not like
yeah so you know I was I thought about
this before I tweeted about it several
months ago but I was thinking about
again about how do we get how what
happened you know what happened did
Trump like take a sledgehammer to the
system the Multiverse shatter and
different realities merged and just like
nothing makes sense technological I'm
I'm racking my brain for what changed
technologically six seven years ago it's
the streaming capability that's
something what were you gonna say well
so no um so you know that whole bit of a
sort of you know everybody under 40
knows that this all started with harambe
but we're not sure why
right you know but I actually I was
talking to a friend of mine recently
um who shall remain nameless but he
actually had a good answer for why we
all sort of agree that it's harambe and
what you know he looked at harambe as a
symbol of society is just subtly out to
get you and they will just kill you for
no reason that even though not not to
get into whether or not harambe should
have been killed but uh you know because
the kitchen in there and all but that
just sort of the larger meta narrative
that's going on there that you could be
hanging out one day and that's in that
Society will just come and boom like a
meat cleaver I I hear the theory I
respect it but I think the more obvious
theory is just that harambe was an
interdimensional Time Lord who was
holding together the the No No for the
members thing you're gonna get us baby
what are you what are you doing you're
gonna shut down completely over here the
uh the guy who killed harambe was like a
secret agent sent from like another
dimension and like you know he walks in
he's like
takes his glasses off the kid was trying
to protect yeah yeah like a future
leader I don't know I actually
Associated a really good one a really
good meme of this recently this is a
quick child you need to under you need
to understand Dr fauci is improving
experiments yeah with with the Wuhan
Institute of you've got to warn okay
he's out thanks for checking out this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time